and since the early 1970s even though he
had booming decades in the 80s and 90s
overall our growth rates since we went
off the Bretton Woods system the old
gold standard in 1971 the US average
growth rates are less than they were
before 1971 and if we had maintained the
growth rates that we had for 180 years
up to 1971 if we'd maintained those
growth rates after 1971 on average the
US economy today would be 50% larger
than it is now Steve Forbes live on book
TVs in-depth Sunday April 3rd noon to
3:00 p.m. Eastern
you're watching book TV on c-span 2 this
weekend were in Long Beach California
with the help of our local cable
partnered charter next presidential
speechwriter for Gerald Ford Craig Smith
shares behind-the-scenes stories from
his time in the White House and the
importance of speech writers during
presidential elections
how did you get started in speech
writing that's an amazing kind of story
I was a high school debater and then I
debated in college and I went on to
double my major from history into
Communication Studies then I went into
graduate school in communication studies
but I never thought of speech writing I
just taught speech and got interested in
various areas of the field and then when
I was at the University of Virginia I
was asked to give a guest lecture at the
University of North Carolina and Chapel
Hill so I went down to Chapel Hill and
gave my lecture at 10 o'clock in the
morning and President Ford was speaking
on the campus at noon and all of us
decided to go over and hear him because
how often do you get to hear a president
live and the president gave a speech
that was really not very good it was
disorganized it was rambling my
colleagues kidded me a lot like how
could you be a Republican and support a
man who can't even give a speech I went
back to Charlottesville and I wrote out
a 5 page single-spaced critique of the
President's speech and then I mailed it
to the White House the president the
United States the White House 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue Washington DC and a
week later I got a call and was asked to
come up an interview for a speech
writing job that was open
now they had checked me out with certain
people they knew that knew me in the
debate world because I was a debate
coach at the University of Virginia and
then I came up and went through the
interview and I got the job and it was
just amazing to me that the first time I
was writing a speech for anybody but
myself was the president United States
it's my first speech writing gig making
a match between a speech writer and the
client is something that happens after
you're hired
some of the best speech writers in the
world did not get along with their
clients it's it's when you find a match
and it you only learn that through the
writing process so for example John
Kennedy went through a number of speech
writers before Ted Sorenson this
legislative aide from Nebraska became
his speechwriter and then they then it
clicked what happened with me was as a
kind of hazing I think I was my first
speech was that I was assigned was
right the President's speech for the
Southern Baptist Convention meeting in
Norfolk Virginia in 1976 so here you had
a Catholic writing for an Episcopalian
to speak in front of the Southern
Baptists and it looked like a very
difficult assignment we were running
against Jimmy Carter who was a
born-again and loved by the Southern
Baptists and he had spoken there and
brought the house down so it was a very
tough assignment
we went down to Norfolk the president
got up with my speech which had gone
through ten drafts the art of writing is
rewriting and he was about a minute and
30 seconds into the speech and he was
interrupted by applause and it kind of
threw him off because it didn't happen
Dan very often he kind of lost his place
got back on script he was interrupted 15
more times by applause the Washington
Times wrote up the speech as one of the
best that Ford had ever given and so
suddenly Ford President Ford and I were
together as speech writer and client and
it went on successfully from that point
forward why did that speech resonate
with the crowd I think it's because I
understood that audience analysis is
critical to giving a good speech
I mean Aristotle tells us that the
strategies that you use in the speech
should literally come out of the
audience so I had done advance work on
that audience you know there were a lot
of evangelical ministers there I had
talked to Southern Baptist preachers and
I think adapting to the audience was the
first step the second step that made the
president very comfortable I think was
the organization of the speech he knew
where he was going
speeches are invisible they're not like
writing and so you and people only
retain about a third of what they hear
so you have to repeat yourself and you
have to tell people here's where we are
now in the speech here's where we're
going you know now I'm moving into my
conclusion it makes the speaker feel
comfortable makes the audience feel
comfortable and I think that's what
happened with that speech after we lost
the presidency I lined up a job at the
University of Alabama Birmingham while I
was teaching at Birmingham
the bill Harris the new head of the
Alabama Republican Party came to me and
said would you help me out I'd have to
sell republicanism to Alabamans and in
the latest poll only 6% of Alabama and
say that they're Republicans so you
could you can see where Alabama's gone
from 1976 to the present it's now a very
red state but then it was a very blue
state and so I went to work for Bill
Harris and we needed to raise money and
so we asked various Republican big names
to come in John Connelly he said no
Ronald Reagan he said no then we asked
George Herbert Walker Bush to come in
and he said yes and so he came and spoke
at a big fundraiser in the Civic Center
in Birmingham now Birmingham was the
Republican City at that time and so we
went to the Civic Center and I was
sitting at a table and near me was this
nerdy young man with blond hair and he
said why don't you tell us what you
think of George Bush's speech and I said
well okay I'll do that so I took notes
as Bush spoke and then when the speech
was done the nerdy young man turned to
me and said what did you think of it and
I said well he's a very nice man he's
obviously very sensitive and very bright
but he needs some organization he needs
a sense of style it's obvious that
speech wasn't rehearsed and he needs to
rehearse and the young man said well my
name is Karl Rove and I worked for him
and how would you like to meet him right
now I can take you upstairs so I went
upstairs I shook hands with mr. Bush and
he invited me to come to Houston to meet
him with him and his wife in January of
1978 so I flew to Houston that January
and came to the house in a three-piece
suit in Houston I was you know all very
formal in the morning and mr. Bush came
to the door and he was in an Izod
t-shirt I'll never forget it was red and
he said if you'll get out of that silly
vest I'll cook you breakfast and so we
went into the kitchen he handed me a cup
of coffee I'm standing there with the
coffee he's cooking me eggs and mrs.
Bush Barbara Bush comes into the room
and she looks at George and then she
looks at me and she says George that
young man is standing there with a cup
of coffee with no saucer under it we
have the Chinese delegation coming in
tonight
and I don't know what got into me but I
said mrs. Bush with all due respect I
came to your door in a three-piece suit
and I'm not gonna spill a drop of this
coffee and she laughed and George
laughed and we hit it off from that
point on and we're friends and so I
became a consulting writer to George
Bush during his campaign and run up to
1980 we won the Iowa caucuses
that we lost in New Hampshire the battle
went all the way to June before George
HW Bush pulled out and then Ronald
Reagan became the nominee and then he
put Bush on the ticket with him and so
then I consider it continue to consult
with mr. Bush Vice President Bush all
that time and then into his next
presidential run in 1988 biggest
challenge for me in writing speeches for
George Bush Senior was that he didn't
like rehearsing he thought it was
unmanly to rehearse and I had to
convince him that Ronald Reagan
rehearsed that other people I had worked
for had rehearsed and that he really
needed to rehearse speeches and when he
rehearsed he was really good in fact the
Wednesday night of the 1980 convention
he gave a terrific speech and that
helped him get on the ticket with Reagan
Reagan was watching and he said I didn't
know the guy could speak that well it
was because he rehearsed a winner to
lead our party to victory in the fall
the American people regardless of party
want a winner in the White House after
four years of Jimmy Carter's bumbling
incompetent leadership
[Applause]
have such a winner and his name is
Ronald Reagan
but every once in a while he would lapse
into not rehearsing and the speech
wouldn't go so well and I have to tell
you the best speech in the world if
delivered badly is a bad speech and
sometimes a bad speech delivered very
well is a good speech regardless of how
badly written it is so delivery is kind
of a bottom line for me when I work with
clients one of the things I do is I
deliver the speech to them before I let
them look at it so that they can hear it
first and then they can look at it they
can see the rhythm they can see the
phrasing because that's really important
when do you know when a speech doesn't
work it's it's you know it's usually
pretty obvious it I'm lucky it rarely
happened for me I mean I don't mean to
brag or anything but my speeches
generally went very well because I
monitored them I made sure that I
rehearsed with with the client but when
I was working for President Ford the
representatives of boys nation came to
the Rose Garden to give him an award and
I had written the speech for him it was
put on cards he took it out he delivered
it beautifully everything went well the
next week the Mormons came to give him a
kind of little statuette reminiscent of
the Mormon pioneer statue in Salt Lake
City and he went out same thing I had
given him the speech on the cards and he
kind of flubbed it and stumbled and I
thought what happened you know what was
wrong so we were walking back from the
Rose Garden to the Oval Office and I
said mr. president with all due respect
the boys nation speech went terrific Lee
today not so much what happened and he
said well they had a motion picture
camera going and I thought I said I
don't understand what what's the problem
he says it makes me nervous when I see a
motion picture camera so here here was a
man who'd given five hundred and thirty
speeches this minority leader of the
house and nobody had determined that he
was camera shy so when we went to Kansas
City for him to give the acceptance of
the nomination at the Republican
convention
in 1976 we rehearsed him in front of
five cameras live and we kept going
through the speech so that by the time
he got up to delivered at the convention
he had gotten over his camera shyness
and he gave a great speech tonight I can
tell you straight away this nation is
sound this nation is secure this nation
is on the march to full economic
recovery and a better quality of life
for all Americans
[Applause]
the speech I wrote that received the
most attention was when I was a
consultant to Governor Pete Wilson
running for president he had a very
short-lived campaign he had lost his
voice
we had trouble fundraising but his
announcement of candidacy was given in
New York Harbor in front of the Statue
of Liberty and he talked about law and
order how much he supported police we
talked about illegal immigration which
is one of the things he was trying to
shut down the speech made the front of
the New York front page of the New York
Times there he was standing there with
the Statue of Liberty behind it and I
must say that's the best reaction I've
ever had to any of the speeches I've
written now the bicentennial speeches
that I coordinated all of them and wrote
two of them in full for the president
got a lot of attention also and a lot of
favorable press and actually put forward
back in the race going into the
Bicentennial we were 33 points behind
Jimmy Carter and everybody had written
off forward in his campaign by the time
we finished the bicentennial speeches we
were only 10 points behind and at the
end of the acceptance speech in Kansas
City Ford was only about 5 points behind
and after the first debate the race was
dead even so you can make a difference
with the speeches that you deliver
particularly in a presidential campaign
debates are really tricky and we have so
many of them now far too many in my
opinion that it's very difficult for
speech writers to do as much good as as
they can with stump speeches I mean I
felt so bad for Senator Marco Rubio when
they had given him a line and he kept
repeating the line which wasn't directly
responsive to the question it was the
beginning of the unraveling of his
campaign you also have someone who's
ignoring his speech writers somebody
like Donald Trump making fun as if he
was in junior high of people saying
women don't look very good referring to
Carly fiorina's face I mean speech
writers would never write things like
that so there's been this deterioration
in the rhetoric of the candidates and
you you you you you don't see the
opportunity to write the good
Beach now there are exceptions Marco
Rubio has given very good acceptance
speeches on campaign days Hillary
Clinton has gone from a wooden strident
speaker in 1996 if you look at her
victory speech after the South Carolina
primary that speech is extremely
well-written extremely well rehearsed
and very well delivered it's its best
speech I've ever seen and give instead
of building walls we need to be tearing
down barriers we need to show by
everything we do that we really are in
this together so there's a place for the
speech writers they're still working
they're still doing things I know that
Jeb Bush called in some people to get
some help and it improved him in the
debates but it was too late
the debates are really difficult things
can go wrong when I was coaching
President Ford as I said we won the
first debate in the race was dead even
we were very optimistic that we would
win in the second debate we knew that it
was foreign policy it was at the Palace
of the Arts in San Francisco we knew the
president was going to be asked about
his policy of date on with the Soviet
Union in answering that question he said
look Yugoslavia has remained independent
of the Soviet Union Romania is moving in
that direction Poland is not dominated
by the Soviet Union and then Max Frankel
of the New York Times asked to follow up
I'm sorry I could I just found it under
stand you to say sir that the Russians
are not using Eastern Europe as their
own sphere of influence and occupying
most of the countries there and and
making sure with their troops that it's
a that it's a communist zone whereas on
our side of the line the Italians and
the French are still flirting with I
don't believe mr. Franco that the
Yugoslavians consider themselves
dominated by the Soviet Union I don't
believe that the Romanians consider
themselves dominated by the Soviet Union
I don't believe that the poles consider
themselves dominated by the Soviet Union
well immediately after the debate we
went up to the president's do Spencer
his advisor said mr. president you
misspoke yourself you're gonna have to
hold a press conference immediately and
explain what you meant and the president
said what did I say and Stu said well
you said that the Soviet Union doesn't
dominate Poland and the president said I
didn't say that and Stu said well what
did you say what do you think you said
and the president said I said that the
Soviet Union does not dominate the
Polish people in their minds and in
their hearts and we played back what the
president said and he said oh my god
that's I thought I said in their hearts
and in their minds I I left that phrase
off we'll hold a press conference and
clear this up Henry Kissinger came up
and said what's going on we explained to
Kissinger what what had happened and
Kissinger said you can't say that
it'll insult the Soviets and I'm trying
to get Anatoly Sharansky
out of the Soviet Union well they
debated it for five days and during
those five days the election slipped
away the people were reminded that
President had tripped and fallen he was
made fun of by Chevy Chase on Saturday
Night Live all of that came back and he
became the mistake-prone president
because of this mistake he did correct
the record five days later in California
but it was too late it had all gotten
away so debates are really dangerous
they're really scary speech writers are
very important to current campaigns and
you just start by saying that bottom
line speech writers are incredibly
important in terms of getting the
phrasing down so that it means something
you know Hillary says we shouldn't be
building walls we should be breaking
down barriers that's a beautiful phrase
because you got up and down you've got
the alliteration of breaking down
barriers that's a well well turned
phrase and it becomes a campaign slogan
she says it all the time now so I think
those are the kinds of things that
speech writers can do for a campaign to
give it cohesiveness for more
information on book TV's recent visit to
Long Beach and the many other
destinations on our cities tour go to
c-span org slash cities tour
tonight were thrilled to welcome
award-winning journalist and news anchor
Jorge Ramos fresh off the heels of last
week's democratic debate which he
moderated with the same integrity and
no-holds-barred approach that you've
seen him exhibit in his role as
Univision's lead news anchor since 1986
more than 2 million people tuned in
daily to his nightly newscasts Horsa
Jorge also hosts Univision's weekly
public affair program al punto as well
as America with Jorge Ramos on fusion he
writes a weekly column that is
distributed by the New York Times
syndicate take a stand lessons from
rebels is a retrospective that looks
back on the groundbreaking interviews
Jorge has conducted during his 30 years
as a journalist with everyone from
President Obama to Fidel Castro those
interviews taught Jorge about himself
and the world we live in and in
revisiting those lessons in the book he
offers readers a uniquely informed lens
for how to think critically about key
issues affecting the world today the
timeliness of this book cannot be
overstated
Ramos also shines a light on the
concerns that influence Hispanics the
largest minority in America a Mexico
City native and the author of 10 books
Jorge has been instrumental in promoting
literacy among Latinos and is a powerful
and public voice for immigrants rights
I'm the owner of DJ's delicatessen in
Dupont Circle we employ a number of
first-generation immigrants and I've
seen firsthand how this group trusts or
a as their voice box and a guide in a
new America Jorge has won eight Emmy
Awards for Excellence in Journalism time
has included him in the magazine's
hundred most influential people list and
called him one of the 25 most
influential Hispanics in America as a
friend of Jorge's daughter I can also
say there's a pretty awesome father
please join me in welcoming Jorge Ramos
[Applause]
obviously I know him otherwise he
wouldn't be talking like that right Nick
thanks so much thank you so much thank
you all for being here
most attentive London England Paquito
pork is you know knows Valentin there
okay so so so we'll do it we'll do it in
English and then a little bit of
Spanglish and then every once in a while
in Spanish but here's the idea
we're gonna be together for the next
hour so let's take advantage of that
I really hate long speeches because I'm
not running for anything even though
some people might think I am and but the
idea is that I'll speak for a few
minutes and then we have two microphones
here and I would love to hear your
comments many of the things that I do
I'm sure you don't like and I'm fine
with that
so let's let's have a conversation
because right now is fantastic though
the fact that we are in the middle of a
very intense campaign and let me tell
you where I come from I come from a
country in which when I was your age
when I was 20 21 22 there was simply no
democracy I come from a country in which
in the last 10 years 80 journalists have
been killed obviously I'm talking about
Mexico and look what's happening here we
can come here and I can criticize the
President of the United States
I can criticize your friend Donald Trump
I can criticize Hillary Clinton Bernie
Sanders Ted Cruz Marco Rubio and nothing
absolutely nothing happens in other
words that's the beauty of democracy in
this country and we just take it for
granted I go home and go to the
supermarket I take a walk they play
tennis go for a jog and nothing
absolutely nothing happens because
that's the way democracy works here and
it's beautiful
I still remember the last time when I
talked to President Barack Obama we had
a disagreement on deportations I was
telling him that he should not have
deported more than 2 and a half million
undocumented immigrants and he didn't
agree with me and and you know what
happened afterwards nothing
and it's isn't that beautiful the the
most powerful man on earth didn't agree
with me which was fine and then I went
home and nothing happened just imagine
what would have happen in Honduras or in
Mexico or in Brazil or in many other
countries and that's that's precisely
the thing that I am celebrating let me
just start by by asking you to take a
look at me because I'm a dinosaur
I'm a dinosaur yeah
and I'm making a huge effort trying not
to be a dinosaur but I'm a dinosaur
because what I'm being asking from you
for the last 30 years
and the reason why I'm published in this
book right now is I'm gonna be it's
gonna be my 30th anniversary as an
anchorman for noticiero Univision each
each one of these ganas each one has a
name or maybe like five Trump's over
here but what's what's really
interesting is that I've been asking
from you to watch the newscast every
single day at 6:30 p.m. if you tuned in
at 6:29 you cannot see me if you tuned
in at 7:01 I'm not there so I'm a
dinosaur right because that kind of
appointment TV that kind of requirement
that I've been asking from each one of
you and from millions of people is no
longer valid and and everything is
changing because there are some
migration of eyes from TV and c-span is
here and thank you suspend for having an
interest on what we're doing right now
honestly because it's it's important but
there's a migration of eyes from TV to
cell phones and maybe I should have
asked for your permission but you're on
Facebook live right now you want to help
me
here you're gonna so you're on Facebook
live
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alright let me tell you what's what's
happening the the thing is that in the
last Super Tuesday for instance we were
broadcasting on Univision and on fusion
in English and then at the same time we
decided to broadcast on Facebook life
and guess what millions of people
millions of people decided to watch what
we were doing on Facebook on a cell
phone and not on TV and many of you know
exactly what I'm talking about on I'm
doing a weekly show on fusion
and half the people who are watching
what we do don't even own a TV in other
words I am producing a TV show for
people who don't own a TV and that's
that's amazing
now if you're studying journalism or
communications let me tell you something
we don't know how to make money out of
that because through ads on TV it's a
different is a different idea we know
exactly how that works but how do you
make money if you decide to broadcast
through social media through the cell
phones that's completely different now
that doesn't mean that is not a great
time to be a journalist because I think
right now is the best time to be a
journalist when you have millions of
information millions of tidbits of
information on the internet then what's
the value of being a journalist well I
think it's important I think the value
of being a journalist resides on your
credibility if what I say every night if
you don't believe what I say my job as a
journalist will amaze absolutely
absolutely no sense so that's one of the
revolutions that I wanted to talk with
you tonight
that's this technological revolution in
which millions of eyes are migrating to
your cell phones and that's where news
are gonna be it's better work every
single morning I wake up and I check on
social media not on the New York Times I
still they could to get the New York
Times I read it every morning
The Washington Post L by L by a mahira a
few newspapers I love to touch the paper
but many of you really are saying what
are you talking about no that's what
you're a dinosaur I'm sure that's what
you're thinking
well
I still love to do that but the fact is
that if there's a breaking news if
there's an earthquake in China or
gunfire in Los Angeles or a candidate
says something interesting in Chicago
Ohio or Orlando right now I cannot
compete I cannot compete with Facebook I
can compete with Twitter I cannot
compete with snapshot I can't compete
with Instagram I'm not there so as a
reporter instead of rejecting that as
many reporters have been doing we just
have to embrace the new technologies so
that's the first revolution I wanted to
tell you about the second revolution has
to do with what I call la olla latina
when when I first arrived in the United
States there were 15 million Latinos
right now there are 55 and in 20 55 2055
would be a good year because I would
turn 97 if I'm here but but many of you
will be here and in 20 55 I'll be dead
right in 20 55 look what's what's gonna
happen in 20 55 this is based on our own
Pew Research numbers the white
population in this country the white
non-hispanic population in this country
will become another minority think about
it so these will become a country of
minorities think about it how although
all what that means it means that what I
am living right now in Miami for 70%
Latino or when you go to a hospital to
see the babies in Los Angeles or when
you go to a school in Houston or Chicago
that's precisely the future we are in a
multicultural multiracial multi-ethnic
country and that's precisely what we are
seeing
it's an incredible demographic
revolution that I am celebrating but not
everyone is a
many people are scared many people are
not embracing this change and that's
precisely what I think we are seeing
with Donald Trump in some of his
followers now we'll talk a little bit
about Donald Trump just just a little
everybody's talking about Donald Trump
right he's changing honestly the dynamic
of this campaign but I think that he has
a nostalgic view of the United States
when he says we're gonna make America
great he wants to send us back to where
we were and honestly to a place that
many of us did not like I mean we don't
want to go back to racism and we don't
want to go back to discrimination and I
think right now in this country we are
going in terms of the Latino growth this
demographic revolution we're going from
big numbers to power for the first time
for the first time we sense we're
getting a sense of what it is to have
power and many of you are Latinos how
many of you speak Spanish or are Latinos
the we are just a few miles from the
White House and look how we are changing
what's going on in this country and look
I've said this many many times but this
demographic revolution could be seen and
felt everywhere the music that we are
listening to in this country it's full
of our rhythms no it is Ricky Martin and
Shakira and J Balvin evolving there you
go let me give you a beautiful example I
had the privilege of interviewing Sonia
Sotomayor which is one of my is one of
my heroes exactly she's just fantastic
right and then think of Sonia Sotomayor
when she was a little girl she was
diagnosed with diabetes and very early
on she learned how to administer insulin
shots to survive also very early on
Sonia Sotomayor and she's one of the
that I interview for the book she
learned that she had to live life to the
fullest so I went to the Supreme Court
to talk to her and then and then we had
a plan because on TB TB doesn't happen
TB has to be produced is not something
that you take for granted there's a lot
of things behind television and then we
thought how about if at the end of the
interview we put salsa music real loud
to see what happens and then we did the
experiment with the Supreme Court
justice can you imagine that so we went
to the Supreme Court justice my my Cuban
producers brought salsa and then I
finished the interview I gave them the
sign and then power salsa music in the
Supreme Court and then guess guess what
happened with Sonia Sotomayor he she
stood up and then she told me do you
wanna dance and we danced and we danced
and and the picture is here is it's in
the book that's precisely what I'm
saying that we are transforming
everything here in the United States
I've said also this in the past more
salsa has been sold and ketchup and more
tortilla it is true
Nick yeah he's a restauranteur you know
right okay more more tortillas than
bagels and hamburger buns and you're
saying this man what is he saying well
that's that's true we're changing
absolutely everything here in the United
States and then I don't know why I'm
sensing that many of you are liberal
here but but think of this for the first
time in history we have two latinos
running for the White House and even
though the majority of Latinos in this
country vote for the Democratic Party
it's about 70 percent for the Democratic
Party more thirty percent any changes
the reality is that the new normal for
and isn't that great the new normal for
us is that to Latinos could become I
don't know what's gonna happen after
Florida tomorrow but I can say that
today to Latinos could become the next
president of the United States think
about it
no it's in that just fantastic we're
talking about two sons of immigrants
Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz but not only
that Donald Trump is also a son of
immigrants so for the first time we have
yeah it's true
losing my voice here his mother is from
Scotland and so he's a son of immigrants
and what's so interesting is that again
for the first time we have the
possibility that two latinos could
become the next president of the united
states and their 4445 so if it doesn't
happen this year might happen in 2020 or
2024 it doesn't matter but the fact is
that we have gone again Latinos from big
numbers to power for the first time and
that's a huge change and I think it is
incredibly important that we realize
that that new power is here and that we
can talk about things that in the past
we really have no chance to talk about
and in therefore when we have a
candidate who says Donald Trump that
Mexican immigrants are rapists and
criminals and drug traffickers I think
there's a new power and we can respond
to that and we responded to that what's
so interesting is that let me just put
in a question where were all the
candidates nine months ago where was the
press nine months ago where was the US
government and the Mexican government
nine months ago when Donald Trump said
that Mexican immigrants were criminals
and drug traffickers and rapists where
were they nowhere to be found
nowhere to be found and then we
responded we Latinos responded we said
no you're absolutely wrong what you're
saying mr. Trump is not right and it's
absolutely
and we responded we just didn't wait for
another set of Chavez and we didn't wait
for the Latino candidates and we didn't
wait for the Hispanic congressmen to
respond we responded and there it was J
Balvin who responded it was Christian de
la Fuente it was all our artists and
each one of you on social media who
saying what you are saying mr. Trump is
absolutely wrong the batman europe
immigrants just see the studies are not
criminals nor a pest he wants to build a
1900 mile wall between Mexico in the
United States good luck you know why
because almost 40 percent of immigrants
undocumented immigrants come by plane or
with a visa so he wants a big wall well
I mean it's gonna have to be a really
big wall for that no and then he wants
to change the Constitution and deny
citizenship to the children whose
parents are undocumented well he would
have to change the constitution for that
and in other words he's absolutely wrong
and I think we have the right to start
changing the conversation and I think we
are changing the conversation talking
about Latino power
okay let's suppose that he wants he's
saying that he's gonna win the Hispanic
vote and let me tell you some news mr.
Trump you're not going to win the
Hispanic vote this
these are these are the numbers that I
got from the Univision Washington Post
poll a few a few days ago 81% or Latinos
have a negative opinion of Donald Trump
81% so how would that what would that
mean in terms of if he were to run
against Hillary Clinton or Bernie
Sanders well only 16% of Latinos
16% I know you're asking who well who's
that 16 percent but 16 percent of
Latinos would vote for Donald Trump
against Hillary Clinton or Bernie
Sanders 16 percent can he win the White
House with 16 percent no he can't
because remember Mitt Romney got 27
percent of the Hispanic vote and he lost
the election John McCain got 31 percent
of the Hispanic vote and he lost the
election so with 16 percent of the
Hispanic vote Donald Trump cannot win
the White House and that is where our
power resides precisely we have 27
million Latinos 27 million Latinos who
are eligible to vote unfortunately not
all of Latinos go to vote but I think
Donald Trump is helping us because many
Latinos who are thinking well I'm not
gonna go to vote they see Donald Trump
say oh yes I'm gonna go to vote and and
that's changing so 13 million 14 million
Latinos going to the polls in November
the 8th can change and and I'm
completely convinced that no one
absolutely no one can make it to the
White House right now without that
Hispanic vote and that's where our power
resides in that power in which one by
one we are saying no no no let me put in
perspective let's say that only 13 or 14
million Latinos go to the polls in the
last election President Barack Obama won
by less than 5 million votes
so 13 million votes 30 million Latinos
vote could easily change the
conversation so that's my political
speech and I'll just put it aside and
let me just tell you a little bit about
about the book and why it is it is
connected I think that
after my encounter with Donald Trump and
let me let me put it in perspective when
when he said that Mexican immigrants
were rapists and criminals I said well I
I did what any other journalist would
have done I sent him a handwritten note
and send it via FedEx to New York I
expected a response and I got one he
published on the internet my letter with
my cell phone number in it so I had I
had to change my cell phone number and
then I said okay all right that's good
that's your response so I was looking
for Donald Trump for a few weeks and I
found that he was gonna give a press
conference in Dubuque Iowa and then I
thought well Dubuque Iowa I don't think
a lot of Germans are gonna be in Dubuque
Iowa so I bought a ticket and went to
the Buick Iowa and then I decided to
confront Donald Trump in a press
conference and I was not very successful
I was ejected from a press conference
it's the first time in 30 years in which
I've been ejected from a press
conference for the first time what's
interesting is that I was ejected by one
of his bodyguards the only other time in
which I've been prevented from asking a
question with a bodyguard was with Fidel
Castro in 1991 in walala Hara I asked
Fidel Castro about the lack of democracy
in Cuba Wow 1991 in 2016 President
Barack Obama is going next Monday to to
Cuba and nothing has changed right well
that's another conversation but but the
fact is that I was prevented from asking
a question by Fidel Castro's bodyguard
and I have an interview with Fidel
Castro I don't know if I can call it an
interview it lasted 63 seconds before I
was pushed by a bodyguard but I think it
lasted a little longer than my encounter
with Donald Trump I think only lasted a
few a few seconds now I think it is
dangerous when a presidential candidate
attacks minorities because after he told
me Trump told me go back to Univision
just a few seconds later just a few
seconds later outside the press
conference somebody told me get out of
my country he told me that get out of my
country and then I thought I look around
said I'm a US citizen where he wanted to
go no but but now that we are seeing
confrontations and violence
in Trump's rallies we know where is that
come from precisely because I leave that
I know I think discrimination and hatred
is contagious just a few seconds after
he said go back to Univision somebody
told me somebody told me get out of my
country and if that happened to me or
national television what could happen to
many others so I think that when it
comes to and this goes directly to the
essence of my book take a stand they the
editor and the photographer they thought
that I should have been standing up and
that's one of the reasons why I I
decided to stand up when I was with
Donald Trump because I I thought that
had I been sitting down he told me I
don't know how many times sit down sit
down and said no of course I'm not gonna
sit down and I nothing it's important
because it's body language if you are at
the same level if you're standing up
you're exactly the same level as the
candidate or the member of Congress or
the president in it it's it's completely
different and I think when it comes when
do you have to stand up think about it
when when when it is okay for you to
stand up to say no I'm not gonna do that
well as a journalist I think you have to
take a stand because I've been asked are
you a journalist or an activist well I'm
just a journalist who asked question but
in certain situations you have to take a
stand when it comes to
yeah and you do that all the time when
when do you take a stand well you take a
stand when when it has to do with racism
discrimination corruption public lies
dictatorships or human rights on those
situations as a journalist you have to
take a stand the owner but you're not
objective you're not being neutral of
course not I mean can I be neutral when
someone is promoting hatred and racism
can I be neutral when I talked to Vidal
Castro can I treat Fidel Castro or can I
treat over Chavez
the same way as the victims of the Cuban
dictatorship or as the victims of the
authoritarian government in in Venezuela
can I do that of course not I think you
have to take a stand I cannot treat
Fidel Castro the same way as a victim of
the dictatorship and that's when you
have to take a stand and each one of you
I'm sure you got to take a stand on
certain situations I interview many
Cuban dissidents who at this point have
no alternative in other words we don't
know exactly what's going to happen with
Cuba I think that President Barack
Obama's trip to Cuba they don't want to
admit it and they cannot admit it but
behind the plan of going to Cuba there's
the idea that soft power in other words
more communications more contacts more
visas or journalists more traveling
could change eventually the Cuban regime
they can't say that can you imagine
going to Raul Castro in and I I know I'm
gonna hate it when President Barack
Obama says President President Raul
Castro because he's not a president he's
a dictator but the idea behind it is
that more contacts eventually could lead
to a change in Cuba and I certainly hope
so I I hope that I can take power Ola
and Nikolas
both of them have Cuban Cuban blood they
born in in Miami I hope I can take them
where their grandparents live in in Cuba
but the dissidents in Cuba cannot do
that so they took a stand and you know
the Cuban dissidents they they have a
beautiful world what's the strongest
word in any language it is no no that's
it they they don't know what's going to
happen in Cuba they don't know what's
the next step but they learn how to say
no and that's an incredibly strong word
that's exactly what Lillian teen Torre
which I interview also for the book is
saying to the Maduro regime no I mean
simply no and in that word is the first
thing you have to do to take a stamp
maybe you don't know what's next but you
know what's right and sometimes when you
just say no that's a first step the idea
behind the book came not by any
precedent or by any political leader but
by for dreamers and these dreamers six
years ago they decided to do something
incredibly crazy many people thought it
was he was not it was it was crazy
they they wanted to go walking all the
way from Miami to here to Washington DC
they had no papers they were
undocumented and the first thing I
thought and many people thought was
they're gonna be detained in Orlando or
before they're gonna get arrested and
they're gonna be thrown out of the
United States and sent to a country that
they don't even recognize and they
didn't care and they decided to go all
the way to DC they came all the way to
DC and they started changing the
conversation because their parents
before them before the dreamers and I'm
sure many of you are dreamers yeah good
you change the conversation because your
parents
they were hiding and they thought that
the best way to survive that they had to
sacrifice themselves and they thought we
rather don't move let's live in the
shadows and if we don't make noise scene
awesome or read oh we're gonna be better
off because back then it was incredibly
dangerous for them to move and they were
investing in their future for you for
many of you for many of the dreamers and
these new generation of dreamers they
say no I don't want to live that way
anymore and they took the risk of
walking all the way from Miami to DC and
they started changing the conversation
do you remember when President Barack
Obama said that he did not have the
authority to change the law for
executive action he was not a king or an
emperor and then the dreamers slowly
convinced the president that he did have
the authority and now we have to wait
for the Supreme Court to to make a
ruling in this this summer so they are
the first lesson that I learned from the
dreamers is that it doesn't matter what
you do the first step is to lose the
fear we all have fears they have fears
but if you don't lose that fear at the
beginning if you don't become a rebel
then nothing nothing really is gonna
change and I think every single person
that I include in in the book from
billionaires to presidents to rebels to
dreamers to dissidents they started with
recognizing that they were fearful but
that if they didn't take that step
nothing could have been achieved and
then let me just finish with with a
wonderful anecdote from Desmond Tutu as
you know Desmond Tutu he fought with
Nelson Mandela to change South Africa
and I just wish that I could have the
energy and and to laugh with such
enthusiasm as Desmond Tutu but he told
me something something beautiful I asked
him so
what should we learn from you why should
we learn him with it within the Hispanic
community from the struggle in South
Africa he told me but you have to know
is that it doesn't matter what happens
that at the end you're gonna win and
that just wonderful that's just
fantastic the idea that at the end
you're absolutely convinced that you're
gonna win well each one of the rebels
that I include in the book but
especially especially the dreamers they
were convinced that at the end they were
gonna win and and I think the the idea
behind the book I include in the last in
the last three years as a journalist I
mean to read more than thirty people
that I include that I include for the
book and and I draw a lesson from each
one I think that the most important
lesson as a rebel I learned from my
mother she's 82 she's still walking and
very dangerously but she's still driving
but but what I learned from her and I
finished with this and then we'll have a
conversation what I learned from her is
that when she was growing up in Mexico
and let me put it in perspective we are
five kids I'm the oldest and each year
she had another one and another one and
another one
so five together or four boys in one
girl my father kept on trying on here he
was gonna get she he wanted to he wanted
a girl and and and he was it was back
then in Mexico that was the only way but
then my mother when she was growing up
she was think about it she was not
allowed to go to high school forget
about college she was not allowed to go
to cut to high school and then when I
was old enough to go to college she had
she said that's it I mean I what am I
gonna do
she was young and she had all of her
energy and she had been a wonderful
mother for many years but she needed
much more and then
there was a major fight in my house with
my father and then she said I don't I
don't care what you what you want I'm
gonna go to college my father saw her
with her I said what are you talking she
said I'm gonna go to college so my mom
went to high school and then she went to
college with me so just imagine she went
to college with me and it's a it's a
true story we went to Universidad
ibero-american in Mexico City and then I
will I would see my mom in the corridors
of the university going from classroom
to classroom and there she was the first
rebel that I that I that I knew my
mother who broke all the rules who
fought with my father who challenged
every rule just to go to college and do
whatever she wants and that was my rebel
my mom so that changed me and that
changed the way I think about what's
important and how just little actions no
little actions of rebelliousness can
change a lot of things and each one of
you of course can change that so on so
that's my speech and I will let me just
hear from you okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what I learn as a journalist
every question has to have has to be a
question right so thank you
Facebook you want to say goodbye to the
Facebook people thank you thank you so
much for being there you'll see it's
amazing what Facebook is doing it's
amazing it's changing my industry so can
I go I'm gonna talk c-span I'm sorry I'm
gonna go downstairs okay who wants sorry
go ahead
no Jess Jorge my name is Corinne sorry
Oh denied meant a Columbiana I'm just
gonna get a quick little background and
then I'll ask my question hey I am a
journalism and a political science
student at the University of Maryland I
was undocumented for 15 years and I see
the person that you are for our
community and you are one of the very
few leaders in my opinion for Latinos
and for immigrants and I appreciate that
and want to thank you personally for
that you are a hero for me
you're a hero for me as I learn from you
where you first
Jorge an activist or were you first
Jorge a journalist because we know that
journalism is a profession in which you
advocate and talk about in justices and
I wanted to know about your personal
view on that so thank you I neither one
I think first I was an immigrant in that
change that's changing my my hope you
when I go to Mexico
they say your room green room go back to
the United States right here in the
United States a trauma supported told me
go back to your country so that's what
happens when you're an immigrant Alexis
de Tocqueville
the great French historian he used to
say that the powerful and the rich never
never got into Excel I became an
immigrant because I I had to be an
immigrant no I didn't want to be an
immigrant it would have been great to be
my house and stay home but I couldn't so
for being an activist or before being a
journalist I'm an immigrant in that
change my whole perspective thank you
Thank You Jorge my name is Joe I'm a
journalist as well and I'd like to ask
if you weren't covering the election
this year what stories would you be
chasing right now in the United States
wherever well I I would again because of
where I come from I I think the the
tragedy of the immigrants coming from
Syria and Libya crossing risking their
lives in the Mediterranean going to
Greece and Italy I think that's the
story what I would love to be right now
instead of covering the election here
that's not what I would be I think so
it's it's a as important as as what we
were living in this country and then I
always think that today one of the best
journalists in Mexico Carmen Ortega he's
been off she's been out here for one
year today and you know what happened in
Mexico the she denounced that the
Mexican president and his wife Erika
pena nieto that they they bought a house
a seven million dollar house from a
government contractor can you imagine
them and then you would think okay so
they're gonna lose your job right or
something's gonna happen now the ones
who lost their job were the journalists
who denounced that so I always think
that if I had been in Mexico I would be
unemployed I guess or worse think of the
IDE Mexican journalists who are being
killed so thanks for the question
hola my name is Jesse Lyon emergeny from
San Diego just moved to DC about a year
ago and it's an honor to be here my
question for you is what do you think is
the best solution to address the
clandestine activities associated with
the drug trade especially those
adversely affecting our youth like
addiction gang violence and even the sex
trade and the reason I asked is the
following I'm not a journalist I when
people see me I went to Harvard I went
to the Kennedy School I went to UC
Berkeley undergrad went to UPenn
post-grad I used to manage the
foundation for JPMorgan Chase out of
Miami
Bank of America before that and now I'm
here with the US government and since I
moved to DC my level of frustration of
policies being created by and those that
do not represent our community get
really frustrating so the question comes
from a place of I'm a former total
covered in tattoos at 11 years old I was
sexually abused at 12 I became a sex
worker in the sex trade by force by the
time I was 14 I had 400 sex partners by
force and I was drugged at 16 I was
living in East LA